in the south of France
her restaurant had no equal last night
we serve this in this restaurant the
cuisine is not an old tired marriage it
is a passionate affair until one family
why exactly are you living London it's
stupid stir things up I want to buy this
restaurant this is private property it
shows me do you own this property no oh
that means you're trespassing to 100
feet across the street the restaurant
has a Michelin star I know I saw it
twinkle twinkle so what we open Saturday
night my son is the best Indian chef in
your update your hand don't you change
waiting party for that a funeral the
death of good taste if your food is
anything like your music I suggest you
tone it down I will turn the music down
but I will turn the heat up I relax what
do you mean relax spoil the whole game
the restaurant is her entire life ever
since her husband died but LOV knows in
just one mouthful they first chef has
the potential to be great you seduced
his mind with your that is called
subtlety of flavor and that is what he
will learn in my kitchen he as good as I
think his
I added some spices why change our
recipe that is 200 years old maybe 200
years is long enough